20 років там стояв паркан, який Саакашвілі прийшов і просто знищив
відкривши таким чином доступ до узбережжя для одеситів
У 2015-му, коли губернатором Одеси став Міхеіл Саакашвілі
громадський активіст Віталій Устименко мав багато сподівань
що в регіоні врешті-решт відбудуться довгоочікувані зміни
пляжі відкриються для всіх, а не тільки для олігархів
припинитьсямасштабна незаконна забудова одеського узбережжя
Він навіть допомагав команді Саакашвілі інспектувати незаконні будмайданчики
Однак ця ініціатива екс-губернатора так і залишилася тільки ініціативою
Це цілий комплекс юридичних таких от робіт, якітреба було зробити
Тому для реалізаціїцього проекту потрібен був час. Один рік, два роки мало бути щонайменше
Віталій не приховує розчарування, що екс-губернатору не вдалося довестицю справу до кінця
Після його відставки місцеві бізнесмени поновили забудову
Зітхає, мовляв, реформи Саакашвілі пішли разом з ним
А були реформи? Які?
Новий губернатор Максим Степанов на посаді лише півроку
Він теж заповзявся звільнити узбережжя Одещини від незаконних забудов
Але обрав шлях юридичної боротьби
Наше недосконале законодавство побудовано таким чином
щоб знести той чи інший збудований маєток, наприклад
в 100 метровій зоні, потрібно відповідно піти до суду
Да,ми в цьому напрямку працюємо
близько 37 таких справ знаходяться в судах, ініційовані мною
Губернатор запевняє, що регіональна влада робить усе, аби антикорупційні реформи мали результат
Прикладом він вважає запроваджений вже після Саакашвілі новий експеримент на митниці
в результаті якого, за його словами, прибутки в держбюджет зросли до 12 мільярдів гривень
Це вдвічі більше, ніж минулого року
У Європейській бізнес-асоціації уважно спостерігають за всіма експериментами на митниці
що тривають впродовж останніх двох років
Єдине, з чим тут погоджуються, це те
що вже немає тієї відверто нахабної корупції, як це було в часи Януковича
Однак на митницю досі не прийшли працювати нові кадри, не збільшилася зарплатня
Тому великого антикорупційного прориву тут не бачать
Неможливо органи центральної влади змінювати локально в регіоні
тому що вся нормативна база йде з центру
У будь-якому випадку не можна в Одесі здійснити експеримент
і зробити тут абсолютно іншу митницю
Самі одесити кажуть: без Саакашвілі - так само як і з ним
Результатів боротьби з корупцією не відчувають
Та вона скрізь ! Що, лише в Одесі?
В нас немаєкорупції! Все добре!
Імовірно, ці антикорупційні реформи проводяться
але нема конкретних результатів, що когось посадили
Активіст Віталій Устименко сподівається
що рано чи пізно результати будуть
Адже нещодавно в Одесі відкрили офіс НАБУ
А в активістів накопичилося багато інформації щодо незаконних дій чиновників і місцевих олігархів